わー勢いができてるお兄ちゃんはじめした像です今日はちょっとね話して話して話して
話して話しマグリット
今日でね話して話して話して話して話し待っていたいと思います宜しくお願いいたし
ます東いうわけでも卒業シーズそして3月が終わって4月から新生活という方多いと
思います今日の動画は第2学級
大学デビューについてお話ししたいと思います宜しくお願い致します大学にかかわらず
会社とか
中学校とかこう言葉専門学校とか短大まあいろんな場所で新生活を始める方多いと思う
ので何かしたも参考になればいいなと思っておりますよろしくお願い致しますで僕ゴム
着がなんでこんな大渕を叩けるかと言いますとあの僕はですね多分なんですけど大学
デビューという
いうものを完璧に成功しているタイプだと自負しているんですよへというようなことを
話させていただきますと僕ですね静岡県の静岡大学に進学したんですけどもそもそも
どこから静岡大学きたかと言いますか吠え発見から来ました富山県の香合卒業して一人
で静岡大学に立ってことをみなさんどういうことがわかってますかね
分かってますかパパ
僕の場合なんですけど僕の高校から静岡県に行った人は
02で僕の知り合いも進学先そのそもそも少なかったんですけどまぁ地元の友達にも
接続気に入る人は02でした
なしもう友達ゼロに知り合い02何があった時に助けてくれる人02完全にその
プレイヤーを一人で静岡県に乗り込んで
大学生
生活を始めたわけなんですよそこからこう色々あってなんやかんや友達とか持ったいい
感じに増えて気づいたらユーチューバーのトップに辿り着いたことをはじめ諸島が今日
は皆さんの新生活の皆さんの大学
いい
re スタートを切る方法をデイズしようと思います宜しくお願い致しますっていう
わけで多分でこういう状況の方多いと思うんですよはわけわかんねえとこに行っちゃっ
てお友達星でも02もう友達ゼロでどうしようマンで不安で不安で不安で夜も眠れねー
って人多いと思うけども安心してください何とかなると思って下さい裸足
完璧なスタートダッシュ
決められたらな話だねそうスタートダッシュを見せてしまっては友達02のまま
ひょっとしたら大学生活を得てしまうかもしれないそんなのやだろうというわけで今
から僕の言うことをよくよく聞いてくださいまあこれが全て正しいと言ってるわけで
ございますあくまで僕の一例として話しているだけなのでこれウのミス率はありません
からこういうことあったからくらいであターン所得たより出る鍋等もラス店です何か
本当に始まったっ
労組大学が挟まったときえとまずもになって
[音楽]
するかと思いましたねぼくどんなないから3月に引っ越して一人暮らしの部屋にいたん
ですけども33週間くらい一言も言葉を話さなかったです
だってそれで人いないんだろうあっマミーと電話してのはもうおかあちゃんとも電話
以外人もの会話がないか水ですっごい不安でした
友達もいないしこのまま大学が始まっちゃうのかうわぁみたいなまぁフアンの皆さんの
ためにその色々教えてあげましょう
宜しくお願いします今もそんな友達いる訳じゃなかったまあけどそう
1人でも2人でもと
同じを作ればもうきっと素敵な大学生活を送れると思うので頑張って下さいね地方から
遠くに来た人頑張ってください
その1まず何をすべきかあのですねー
テンションを上げ過ぎは良くないですスター正しいケアなきゃ大学デビューしなきゃっ
て思っていこう
ギャーギャー華順引かれちゃうんですよ初手でひか姉だからなかなか取り戻すのは
難しいんで
やはりこうギャーギャー言わずにあるこの相手の手口を探るようにちょっとこう
アサシンのごとく愛さちょっとテンション低めでちょっと舌
同じで何さんが一人堤よる中途がいいと思います結構大事ですよあの無理して頑張る人
はないと思うんで
自分の髪に合った友達を見つけるのが大事だと思いますねその2あずあず一人でもいい
から話し人をつくっておいてくださいおそらくなんですけど
ともう自分だけではなく自分の前の人後ろの人もみんな友達ができるかで不安な人が
いると思いますそういう人誰でもいいんで
パットンでもいいから話しかけてみてくださいどこから来たね使ったかでもいいですし
始めますよろしくお願いしますっていう挨拶でもいい性を何か様の海は人としておく
だけでかなり変わると思うので頑張ってみてくださいたびに僕は自分から話し
けることができないタイプの人間なので話しかけてくれたおかげであの助かったタイプ
ですそういうことがされない人もいると思うので自分から話しかけるサビがあれば是非
話しかけた方が良いと思います宜しくお願いいたしますでこっからですあの僕は自慢
じゃないんですけども大学1年生の時めっちゃくっちゃ友達
多かったんですよ実はまあ今じゃそのほとんどが便ラックすらも撮ってませんけど
あの友達をた
3作る方法としては高部活とかサークルってあると思うんです大学あれの見学会にも
行きまくってくださいいろいろあると思いますよね
なんかバスケサークルまあは彼らのビザと困るかもしれない部活とかサークルとか
いろんなところに行けばいろんな新入生と出会いがあるところでまぁなんでもいいんで
そこで call by ことだか馬に行こう
5-2
引っかかれは仲間に入れてもらえたり会話に混ぜたりその後友達になったりするかも
知れません投稿がどこでどう絡み合うかわかんないのが大学ですごく大学二年生の時
友達と結構回ったんですけどチョコもあったかな
まだバス下のサークルに混みに入ってバスケ部も見に行ってバドミントンサークルとか
を見に行った方やと探検部って言う訳わかんない何か男女れ
担任する部活があって
そこも何が合うと思って見に行きました何でも自在とそういうの大自然で興味ない
ところに行くだけでもいいのでこの日か
人と知り合える幅を広げるっていう噂がすごい大事だったけどまぁそういうのがあって
実は私はの一つお友達がめちゃくちゃ多い方だったんですよ
そいやあああああ今じゃあ考えられんだなぁサークル部活の説明会
なるべく行っていろんな人とお腹話さざるを得ない環境を作り出すというのが大事です
これコミュ障の鉄則です自分から行くのではありません話さざるを得ない状況を
作り出すこれが大事です頑張ってみてください同じ県出身の人とはなぜか仲良くなれる
んですよ例えばよ静岡県で出会ったと耶馬溪の人がいると僕はですよ
同じ県出身なんだっ
言ってください変な新銀河はいてそこで仲良くなって肌スベたになったりするので出身
菊の結構大事ですます最初の方だけで言えることなんですけども
固定メンバーであんまりいない方が良いと思いますす+固定メンバーってさこ
一人の人から見るとですねすごく濃いんですよね固定メンバーそんなで5年みたいな
とこに話しかけられるわけないじゃないですかもそこで固まってるわけですから来て
ねーまでいるんじゃなくていろんな人といたり一人でいたりすると案外最初のほうは
話しかけてくる人が多いと思うんでそのまま友達02て可能性もありますけどちょいで
いた離婚なんか単体行動するのって結構大事なんですよなぜなら初期はみんなで
よう求めているからまあ俺から話せるか今ぐらいかなぁ大学1年生の時友達いっぱい
だった私はその後失恋をしたりああああくるに一句なんか思い出づくり感がすげえなか
バカらしくてなんか9時間のボディせるかに襲われたりして何がこのように名を刻み
たいちょっと有名になりたいとか思って youtube に動画を出そうっていう
こと
せ始めて周りの友達に惹かれて1回知り合いがバーっていなくなって友だちがほぼい
なくなって状況になってしまったんですけども僕ユーチューバーにならなければ他の
そのまま友達たくさんのまま長く覚えていただかもしれませんがどうなるかわかんない
んですけども本番の衝動って大事だと思うんで大学生活
まあどこもそうですよ大学だけじゃないどこもそうでしょ等最初が一番大事です
ファースインプレッションであなたの肛門の生活が変わってくるかもしれませんので
ぜひ頑張ってみてください懐かしいようだ
だから twitter と facebook めっちゃ同じ大学の人いないかなと
探しなんですけどもあれは辞めたほうがいいですよもういいんで
素敵な大学生活を送りくださいじゃ
[音楽]